that's the thing right at the end of the
day i think everyone is asking the
question what is good content
like what the [ __ ] does that even mean
right because like to some people that's
dumb man yeah to other people it's a gig
video like
we don't know what is good content at
the end i think darman is i mean you
can't say it's bad it's very well
produced it's just like it's just so
absurd and the amount of views is so
absurd yeah so that's what's just kind
of crazy right i think it's just
she didn't say
the amount of views this man brings in
yeah i mean i i could honestly yeah i
think that's the biggest thing because
he he makes well-produced content and
it's just like it's just not
correlational to like kind of like the
views that
these videos are amazingly produced but
the story is just [ __ ] bizarre like
it's like a child
it's really strange because everything
else is amazing right like this these
videos are shot better than like almost
any other youtube video like it's insane
yeah i don't know like i've always found
it fascinating like the kind of whole
question of like what is like a
successful video what is like a good
successful video right because like you
know if you're talking about like okay
is a good is good content one that has
quality yeah right and like how do you
explain the [ __ ] chunk chart video
that has 10 million views you know
that's that's like that's got quality i
don't know what you're talking about
joey but like on on a traditional sense
it's not well it's like it's like you
know like report of the week right you
just right it's like and production
quality is terrible yeah it sucks
but it's like it's amazing because it's
what made youtube great
and i feel that's like a big question
that like a lot of people who are
starting off youtube ask right it's like
you know like they go up to the youtuber
who's been on the platform for a while
being like okay so you're telling me
that in order to be successful i need to
make good content
explain that what is good content good
content is anything that you know you've
taken the time to consider every aspect
of the content you've you consider audio
you consider visuals like you watch a
report of the week video yeah the audio
quality isn't professional but you're
like you can hear it it sounds good
enough it's not it's not unpleasant you
can watch it it's good enough you know
he doesn't try and egregiously clickbait
it he doesn't chase trends you know i
feel like bad content to me is someone
who is just chasing trends for the sake
of it yeah the clickbait is just
disgustingly egregious they're making x
thousands of dollars never considered to
upgrade equipment you know stuff like
that you know if you're if you're a
full-time youtuber
and you're using like a usb mic i'm just
like what bro they're like they're
literally a hundred bucks and the audio
quality difference is insane yeah yeah
there's no excuse in my mind uh other
than oh i don't want to look it's too
complicated it's not that difficult
but i normally notice that the people
who do trace chase trends have like have
like a set shelf life yeah yeah they'll
they will get massive amounts of views
for like one or two years or most and
then or or you'll go to their channel
one video will have a million views one
will have 100 100k yeah and it's like
it's like that's how you can tell like
that's a channel where you're like
probably not making the most consistent
stuff yeah yeah yeah or the your content
you're you're you're clearly just you
know appealing to a wider audience that
doesn't have so much care
about you you're only as worth as much
as your worst performing video
yeah like if you're
if a video that doesn't get in the
algorithm doesn't do well people still
show up and watch it yeah that's how you
can kind of tell i guess that's your
core thing yeah that's that's like what
you know the people who really would
turn up and that's what if you can pull
in
you know uh x amount of views that is
like a healthy amount on your worst
performing video that says a lot i think
yeah uh if you are pulling in a million
views then you pull in 50k i think
something's gone horribly wrong
and though
clearly you're doing something that's
not healthy or sustainable yeah and sure
you can keep tracing chen chasing chen
but
proud
demonstration demonstrator demon slayer
but then that's also where you see
youtubers who start to do questionable
things because they get so desperate for
these views they start doing these
horrible video ideas um you know like
actual like just click bait you know
some real egregious stuff you know it's
like where the prank channels you know
you can look at these clear examples
where they were chasing pranks so much
that it became to the point where it was
no longer afraid yeah well yeah they
they started they would do stuff like
pranks in the hood where these like
white guys were just going like
oh i've seen them they were just trying
it was it was just like a try to get
shot challenge or something like that
what the [ __ ] is this and then they
would also it got to the point where
every single prank channel was paying
actors and then there was like kissing
pregnant women prank and it's just like
this is just like what is this like this
is so beyond clickbait now where you
have to to get views you have to go into
such egregious territory you know and
with the family channels where they
would just
put their [ __ ]
here's my here's my child's uh vasectomy
for 10 million views you know it's like
what is this this is not this is not
something that should be a milestone
it's just you know this are you you joke
right but this is the almost the extent
of these [ __ ] family channels so much
wrong with that they would be like oh
yeah today my children are going to
fight to see who's the strongest 10
million last one to survive gets burger
king i joke but some of these channels
were doing such egregious stuff to their
their children that you you may as well
have put that up for [ __ ] sake yeah
you know what i mean like
i feel like when you chase trends and
you're the kind of person who's willing
to put morals aside to get the views
it's when you really see the worst side
of youtube come out yeah and i'm not
saying if you trace chens you're going
to be doing some horrible stuff on
youtube but it is it is a tasteful way
of doing it
there is a there is an uncomfortable
uh similarity to the people who started
chase trends who so sort of starting to
get at the questionable area yeah and
there's a kind of there's a definitely a
a spectrum yeah distastefulness as i
like yeah yeah and you can tell when
someone's on it
yeah
no because like for me like when i think
when i think about what kind of content
i want to make or what what what good
content is i just i just think back to
that like like i just think back to that
like seed in pokemon or something where
it's just like i remember like the
editor of shonen jump in that series
said like doesn't matter what you make
as long as it's interesting like that
that to me like that to me is like what
sticks out my mind whenever whenever
anyone thinks you know whatever the
algorithm is whatever
video you want to make just has to be
interesting to someone yeah
unfortunately and uh but we've seen the
kind of like toxic
content in traditional media right like
tabloids right it's like
you're you're ruining someone's life to
get content yeah you know it's uh
paparazzi yeah it's a thing as old as
time if someone wants it as someone and
someone's consuming it someone's gonna
make it yeah whether it's good or bad or
not is another question entirely you
know like nobody respects tmz yeah but
tmc exists because it gets views you
know yeah yeah the same is on youtube
you know and these channels are gonna
exist because people are gonna watch
them naked yoga exists on youtube
should it i don't know but people are
watching it